hello everyone and welcome to today's
keynote presentation paving the path
towards physician medicine and
inflammatory bowel diseases presented by
Andres Hertha laurenzo senior director
of translational research Crohn's and
Colitis foundation I'm Alexis Krause of
lab birds and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we are delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by laberd's laberd's is the
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual events and webinars before I
begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to practice speak by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box that appears on the
screen
well answer many of your questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the help desk funds located in the
promotional board at the bottom center
of your screen or use the ask a question
box to let us know that you're having a
problem this presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located in the top
right corner of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Hurtado Lorenzo I will now turn the
presentation over to him thank you very
much for your introduction and for the
invitation to this important webinar
series in precision medicine these are
my disclaimers I have divided my
presentation in five topics first I will
provide a brief introduction to
inflammatory bowel diseases for those in
the audience not familiar with it it
will be followed by a description of
current advances in precision medicine
for IBD in particular related to
prognosis of this course and response to
biological therapy followed by a
description of what I believe are the
biggest challenges in the field and
others
Crypton of IBD plexus the largest
repository and research platform the
Crohn's and Colitis foundation is
building to advanced precision medicine
in IBD inflammatory bowel diseases also
known as IBD are chronic inflammatory
diseases of the gastrointestinal tract
there are two main clinical distinct IBD
presentations Crohn's disease and
ulcerative colitis Crohn's disease is
characterized by segmental inflammation
that extends deep into the inner layers
of the intestinal tissue hence the term
transmural inflammation it occurs
anywhere in the GI tract and symptoms
include not bloody diarrhea weight loss
abdominal pain
in contrast ulcerative colitis is
characterized by diffuse inflammation
limited to colonic mucosa and rectum
bloody diarrhea with post fatal urgency
and abdominal cramps I believe is a
multifactorial pathology and there is
consensus that is the result of the
interplay between genetic susceptibility
altered immune responses intestinal
microbial dysbiosis and environmental
factors yet to be determined I believe
is diagnosed using a series of
laboratory and imaging tests including
routine blood and stool tests and more
specialized antimicrobial set ology
tests like ANCA Aska Sabir that detect
antibodies against specific microbial
antigens imaging tests include
colonoscopy and City and M are a
combination of this test with asta
logical grading of sir mucosal
inflammatory inflow infiltration and
mucosal architecture confirms IBD I
believe has a very heterogeneous disease
course and for this reason
implementation of precision medicine
practices will be ideal for targeted
therapeutic management of based on early
noses an example of this body will
desist course the lies from a Norwegian
prospective cohort study called Epson
that followed patients for ten years as
shown in this figure the disease course
ranges from a disease whose symptoms
severity decrease over time shown in
dark blue to an unremitting this is
characterized by that continue that is
continually active and shown in yellow
this represents 19 percent of patients
with Crohn's disease 32 percent of
patients exhibit recurrent elapsing
symptoms shows in in in red and a small
proportion of patients 3 percent have a
decreasing in symptoms followed by a
rampant increase in the severity over
time shown in light blue overall the
cumulative cumulative disease rates in
Crohn's disease was 90% during the 10
years and 53% of patients experience
severe complication that requires
surgery
the main intestinal complications of I
believe the required surgery are under
matically effect patient quality of life
are strictures and fistulas and
abscesses according to the Montreal
classification persistent uncomplicated
inflammation phenotype is classified as
b1 a structuring behavior is classified
as v2 and is characterized by fibrous
the notic narrowing of the intestinal
lumen also known as structures
penetrating behavior is classified as b3
and is characterized by abscesses and
filters which are abdominal connections
between of the intestine with itself and
all organs as shown in the picture
the current standard approach for 13 I
believe is the step step up approach
that involves assessing how severe a
patient's symptoms are and choosing
treatment based on the severity so for
instance a patient who has smile
symptoms probably will be started on an
imino salicylates or antibiotics a
patient who has more severe symptoms or
hasn't respond to the first line of
treatment might be described prescribed
corticosteroids a meal and
immunomodulatory followed by biologics
like anti TNF alpha antibody or surgery
an alternative treatment paradigm is the
top-down treatment approach this
involves treating the disease more
aggressively early on and with a
combination of treatments the goal here
is to induce and maintain remission as
you can see given the complicated
treatment algorithm the implementation
of precision medicine biomarkers that
can stratify patients at diagnosis
according to the severity and respond to
treatment will eliminate the trial and
error aspects of the step up approach or
the necessary exposure to an effective
and costly treatment of the top-down
approach okay so now you begin to see
what the problem is in IBD the course of
the disease is variable with some
patients having more aggressive disease
than others and characterized by
unremitting disease need for drugs
collation or need for surgery in
addition 50% of patients will experience
severe restriction and complication and
penetrating complications which once
they develop generally require surgery
recurrence after surgery is frequent
dramatically impaired the quality of
life and few cases that might be fatal
in addition about 30% of patients do no
response to biologics which are the best
treatment available and they are known
as primary no responders in addition 15%
of patients who responds lose response
over time
so an origin unmet needs in IBD is there
early detection ideally a diagnosis of
patients with potential aggressive and
complicated disease course and their
response to treatment obviously so
doctors can decide the best effective
treatment options based on the patient's
biological and clinical characteristics
to deliver their DRI drug at the right
time at the right dose to the right
patient and at the same time about the
unnecessary exposure to an effective
therapies which is all together which
altogether represents the core of
precision medicine concept precision
medicine definition defined by the NIH
is an emerging approach for disease
treatment and prevention that takes into
account individual variability in genes
environment and lifestyle for each
person however from the data we'll
present here I would suggest that the
definition be modified to integrate all
biomolecules in addition to genes in
support of this idea I will show you
some of the cutting-edge work leading
the way towards the application of
precision medicine in IBD I will show
you how the integration of genotyping
together with clinical and molecular
phenotyping is paving the path toward
prognostication of aggressive disease
course characterized well and remitting
disease complications and or frequently
relapses and also the prognostication of
response to treatment in particular I
will show you work related to the
unification of genetic risk factors and
the combination of clinical parameters
with molecular phenotypes derived from
transcriptomics microbiome --ax and
molecular endoscopy and their potential
use as prognosis prognosis classifiers I
will start with the current clinical
parameters used for prognostication in
clinical practice current clinical
features used to prosecute this is
disabling disease include
upper gastrointestinal involvement
younger age at diagnosis smoking
perennial disease stricter in or
penetrating disease deep alteration
predictors of no response to biological
therapy with TNF alpha antagonists
include the following parameters longer
disease duration more of more than two
years a small bowel involvement smoking
normal c-reactive protein however these
factors are not enough to accurately
predict disability for a specific
patient at diagnosis so a studies have
been conducted to identify genetic risk
factors of aggressive disease course and
response to treatment currently more
than 240 risk loss I have been as shown
to be associated with IBD the
identification of this risk loss I have
provide insights into the biological
processes underlying the disease such as
epithelial barrier function defects on
inmate innate recognition and response
to microbiota as well as this regulation
of adaptive immune responses highlighted
in red are few of these susceptibility
loci that have been evaluated as
potential genetic markers of prognosis
in particular genetic variants of the
note2 gene which is involved in
microbial recognition has been
associated with structuring or
penetrating behavior in European and
North American cohorts on the other hand
variants of the iír GM a regulatory
modulator of innate immune response and
al-tofah G has been associated with
fiscal icing disease in Italian patients
the interleukin 23 receptor is close eye
a mediator of inflammation has been
associated with both
structuring or penetrating behavior in
Korean and European patients and finally
TNF alpha TF s sf-15 variants have been
associated with structuring or
penetrating behave
in Korean patients however this this
this Llosa
still have a limited effect size that
limits or restricts the use in is a
standard markets so in order to
integrate genotyping of no.2 the
variance along with clinical parameters
to predict disease course Cora Siegel
and colleagues created a multivariate
model to predict and visualize the risk
of complications using this model and
software interface patients and
caregivers can visualize the risk low
medium or high of developing
complications this model was validated
in a cohort of 243 Crohn's disease
patients in the prospect study
this was not an inception cohort so so
that already they have some of the
patients have complications but the
exact communica complication data al
diagnosis was available in addition and
optimal anatomical involvement this is
location is extensive disease and
serological markers were also integrated
together with this a node to be with the
a node to the phenotyping so this is as
integration of clinical phenotypes
together the nod2 genotyping variants
for personalized risk a visualization
now to better characterize how genetic
variation influenced this is prognosis
an important large G was study lead by
James 2d and Kenneth Smith from
Cambridge University in the UK
identified for genome-wide significant
loss I associated with good prognosis
importantly none of these laws I showed
a association with disease
susceptibility and this is very
important because at the end of the day
the main determinants of patient
well-being is not diagnosed itself but
the curse the disease takes over time
this
was a meta-analysis of 2g was cohorts
with a total total of 2734 Crohn's
disease patients good prognosis was
defined as indolent disease with no need
for a minimal Mulla Mulla torus or
surgery bad prognosis was defined as
frequent flaring treatment refractory
trimming with more than two amount of
modulators and two on more than two
abdominal surgeries as a result for loss
I will associate with good prognosis and
the Association were located in in the
in FOXO 3x a CT i GV g FP p 1 and MHC
interested me for example fox of three
expresses a protein that controls
controls the tgf-beta one pathway and
limits inflammation suggesting that this
loss ax are likely involved in the
biology that determines prognosis as
mentioned before these four genes are
not associate with susceptibility which
suggests that this initiation is
governed by different genetics to that
of that drives the disease course and
this is a very important aspect that
suggested the biology and the lagging
prognosis not only have a prognostic
predictive value but opens the doors for
novel therapeutic approaches to control
disease progression
so due to the limited effect size of
single OC and as a standalone
classifiers the incorporation of several
polymorphisms and generation of of
genetic risk scores have been proposed
as better approach to increase
predictive value of these genetic
classifiers as example of this is a very
recent work by the group of romics Ovid
at MGH recently published in the
Official Journal of the Crohn's and
Colitis foundation inflammatory bowel
diseases the goal of the of this study
was to generate genetic risk or to
predict primary non-response 20 TNF
alpha antibody and the rational response
in 231 patients with ulcerative colitis
patients were genotype using alumina
immuno chip and primary no response was
defined as no response at week 12 of
treatment initiation durable response
was defined as maintenance of response
20 month after after 20 months of
treatment response was evaluated using
energy in addition to the genetic
information several clinical parameters
that were evaluated so the the outcomes
were the following
as shown in the left panel seven snips
will associate with primary no response
importantly when clinical parameters
were used alone to predict primarily no
response the RC was only 0.6
in contrast the genetic risk score based
on these seven snips improved the
predicted value for primary no response
with a ROC of 0.85 and combined genetic
and clinical models was very similar to
the genetic risk score alone now
regarding the prediction of durable
response 12 a snips were associated with
do double response and similar to the
prediction of primary no response the
genetic risk score along was superior
than the Cree than the clinical model to
predict durable response with an RC of
setup 0.78 now combination of clinical
and genetic model once again did not
improve the genetic risk score while
very promising and what this is very
promising larger expected studies are
required to confirm clinical utility of
this genetic risk is course in summary I
I can I have shown you that genotyping
has been explored as prognosticator tool
to predict aggressive disease occurs and
responds to treatment several loss I
associate with IBD prognosis have been
identified some of which are also
susceptibility loss I and others are
purely prognosis loss I suggesting that
the contribution of genetics to disease
progression to the six promotion is
independent from the contribution of
genetics to disease susceptibility
however the clinical implication
application still is limited and finally
some data has been generated that
support the notion that composite risk
score might provide an improved
prognosis value and effect size than
using single
those I as a stand-alone classifiers
okay now with chief gears to highlight
very exciting advances in the
integration of clinical parameters along
with molecular phenotyping using
transcriptomics for IBD prognosis
I will first refer to a groundbreaking
work related to the prognosis of a
complicated disease course and response
to treatment in a pediatric IBD cohort
known as the risk is tally this cohort
is the largest well characterized
inception cohort in periodic IBD in
which patients were enrolled at
diagnosis and therefore before treatment
before trimming the aims of this study
were to identify clinical and biological
predictors of complications in Crohn's
disease at diagnosis and to evaluate the
effect of early anti TNF alpha treatment
in reducing the risk of complications
the risks periodic inception cohort is
started in 2008 it is funded entirely by
the Crohn's and Colitis foundation it
consists of 28 sites 25 in USA and 3 in
Canada 1,800 pediatric patients were in
Brawl of which 1,000 are Crohn's disease
patients clinical data and bio samples
were collected and information was
collected every six months for five
years the 3GS follow-up outcomes were
published in a seminal paper in Lancet
by principal investigators sue rocket
arson and lead Edison and collaborators
the methodology consists of consisted of
data collection related to clinical
features antimicrobial serologies gene
expression microbiome genotyping and
response to treatment computational and
by statistical tools were used to
analyze 80 million data points in order
to generate a competing race model for
prediction of complication and a
propensity score matching to assess
early teen anti TNF alpha efficacy
the outcomes of the three year follow-up
were the following according to the
Montero classification out of out of 913
patients that remain it 835 remain
inflammatory or B 154 children develop
structuring complications B 2 and 22
2014 developed penetrating complications
or B 3 as shown in this survival curve
ten point seven percent of patients
develop complication by year tree either
penetrating or restriction complications
now the base prediction model using
clinical phenotype show that severe
positive serology that measures anti
flattening antibodies was associated
with the structure and behavior and
asked a positive severe positive order
age at diagnosis and african-american
race were associated with penetrating
complications to identify potential
prognosis predictors based on gene
expression profiling and the iliad
biopsies obtained at baseline
colonoscopy were used to isolate RNA and
to evaluate global gene expression
profiles using era Nasik these are very
exciting results joined that prognostic
gene expression signatures were
identified this figures show that those
patients who develop penetrating
complications like internal fistula
annual absences per year treat exhibited
a diagnosis of regulating expression of
genes involved in inflammatory processes
and these children developed a
complement a complication which is
inflammatory nature like pistolas and
abscesses in contrast children who at
diagnosis had increased expression of
extracellular matrix genes ECM went to
develop a structuring complications
which are characterized by fibrous
tennis
due to mucosal and submucosal deposition
of extracellular proteins so cellular
matrix proteins these signals are
therefore consistent with the biology of
the complication so yet and this
suggests that the gene expression
signatures might not only be potential
prognosis biomarkers by drivers of the
biology of complications and therefore
they can be potential targets for
therapeutic discovery a concept which is
consistent with that of the G was
prognosis loss I that I mentioned before
this is like shows that the composite
risk model based on clinical features
have had an outlook of 0.66 an
integration of the ECM gene signature
increased the IROC - 0.72 and the
specificity to 71% the positive
predictive value also increased and the
negative predictive value remained very
high with or without gene expression now
to evaluate the effect of early therapy
with anti TNF I'll find reducing
research publications children's were
treated with this biologic drug within
90 days of diagnosis which is defined as
early treatment and analyzed via
propensity score matching the
complication-free survival curve on the
right shows that early treatment with
anti-inflammatory antibody reduce the
risk and I mean anti TNF alpha Nibali
reduce the risk of penetrating
complications shown in red but did not
reduce the risk of developing
structuring complications shown in blue
which is consistent with the notion that
an inflammation independent fibrotic
process drives the biology of the
structure in complication as my battle
as might be predicted from the regulated
profile protects signature this patient
exhibits early in the disease
alright so in summary risk
is the largest study of newly diagnosed
periodic Crohn's disease patients a risk
prediction model for complicated Crohn's
disease a diagnosis based on clinical
and gene expression data was generated
in this model extracellular matrix gene
signatures is associated with
structuring disease and inflammatory
gene signatures is associated with
penetrating disease also early anti TNF
alpha therapy reduced penetrating by not
a stricture and complications so finally
this competing risk model that includes
clinical and in expression data could
help stratify patients to decide the
best personalized treatment options at
diagnosis a subsequent paper from the
risk consortium from the same cohort the
same study evaluated the possibility of
using transcriptional risk score to
predict complicating course for this
published Diwas and eqtls data were
integrated with Aaron aid sickest Alice
from risk this lead to the
identification of 29 genes able to
distinguish disease status and more
importantly prediction of a structuring
and penetrating complications as you can
see in the in the right-hand panel more
importantly yet the transcriptional risk
score was superior to predict
complications compared to the genetic
risk score
Suzanne very new concept and very
promising concept for prognosis okay so
I'll show you very important evidence to
support the use of gene expression
signatures and transcriptional risk
scores to predict complications in IBD
like structuring or penetrating
complications and predict response to
treatment but what about prediction of
aggressive disease course characterized
but with five frequent relapse and the
need for treatment a for need for
feminist
okay in this regard this is another
groundbreaking study from the la víctima
Smith in Cambridge UK that aim to
identify gene expression signatures for
prediction of aggresses this is course
in this study aggressive disease was
defined as unremitting this is which is
continuously active and with frequent
relapses and the request therapy
escalation from him from
immunomodulators all the way to surgery
in contrast iesson disease was defined
as sustained remission in which the
which did not require the physical
escalation for the study 35 patients
with active Crohn's disease and 32
patients with active ulcerative colitis
were enrolled 58% of patients were
enrolled at diagnosis PBMCs were used to
isolate cd8 t-cells and CDA for T cells
and their transcriptional profile
analyzed using every metric Aires and
qpcr as mentioned in patients when this
patients were managed with a step-up
approach as shown here transcriptional
profiling profiling of cd8 t-cells from
patients resulted in the identification
of to gene expression signatures called
IBD 1 and IBD - that s terrific stratify
Crohn's disease and ulcerative colitis
patients in two well-defined groups
namely those with the IBD one signature
are characterized by elevated expression
of differentially expressed genes and
those with IBD two signatures in blue
have lower expression of differentially
expressed genes more importantly the
ability of this gene expression
classifiers to predict discourse both in
Crohn's disease and ulcerative colitis
was also evaluated in particular those
patient expressing the IBD one signature
in red had more aggressive disease
course than that that required drug
in contrast those patients expressing
the IBD to signature in blue exhibited
an indolent disease which did not
require drug escalation so importantly
the use of this gene expression what
classifiers was significantly superior
to that of a clinical risk score or
antimicrobial serologies with Aska to
predict this course as shown in the
middle and right panels this gene
expression signature is classified
represent a very important advance in
IBD precision medicine as it will allow
the decision a diagnosis of whether to
implement a top-down therapeutic
approach in which patients with
aggressive prognosis will be treated
early with biologics and on the other
hand it will prevent the unnecessary
exposure to the side-effects of
biological immuno suppression in
patients with indolent disease the
utility of this gene expression
signatures to guide the treatment
choices between a standard stop step-up
therapy and the first-line use of
biological immunomodulatory drug drugs
is currently being evaluated in a in a
randomized controlled trial called
called the profile study ok so I
provided examples of gene expression
signatures to prognosticator structuring
and penetrating complications and as
well as aggressive disease course
characterized by frequent relapse and
they need for treatment escalation so
what about prediction of response to
treat to treat the response to treatment
in particular biological therapy using
anti TNF alpha or anti integral blockers
the most common biologics uses used in
IBD a very important work this regard
comes from the lap of Philip Yuri from
Oxford University in the UK they
analyzed a number of public gene
expression data sets and identify 65
differentially are abundant cytokines
IBD compared to non IBD controls
importantly among all these cytokines it
was the uncle study named cytokine gene
the highest the highest express one in
Crohn's disease patients more
importantly they demonstrated that
increase in oncostatin m expression
correlated with the severity as shown in
the right panel which was defined by
Stella Nickell score and this means that
the higher the levels of oncostatin m
are the more severe the disease is to
answer the question of whether Acosta T
name could be a predictor of response to
by Oracle therapy they analyzed several
observation and prospective cohorts as
shown in the left panel
90% of patient expressing the so called
high expressionist uncle stat in M model
in red were refractory to anti TNF alpha
antibody therapy as expected
in contrast 85% of patients with low
expression of the oncostatin m model
were responsive to anti TNF alpha
therapy the end point to assess response
to therapy treatment was mucosal healing
another analysis using the two
prospective cohorts for now phase 3
clinical trials for TNF alpha antibody
it was found that before initiation of
the treatment on constatine M levels
were already higher in those patients
with rare factorial selective colitis
compared to those patients with the to
achieve remission or harpa or or had
partial response importantly the
expression levels of Uncas tottenham
remained high eight weeks after
treatment initiation in those patients
that did not respond to treatment
so in summary I have showed you several
examples of very important advances in
the identification of gene expression
signatures that could be used for early
prognosis of complications using the ECM
and in turn in the inflammatory
signatures from the risk study in
addition other signatures like the IBD 1
and IBD - can stratify patients who will
develop an aggressive disease or an
indolent discourse and other signatures
like the oncostatin m and the ECM to
predict response to treatment additional
obviously additional prospective
randomized control trials will help
determine whether these transcriptional
classifiers could indeed be used to
decide the best treatment options
early in the disease and improve patient
outcomes ok now I will switch gears
again to present experimental evidence
supporting the integration of clinical
phenotyping with microbial mixin Alice's
for prognosis of complicated disease
course and response to treatment the
risk study that I mentioned earlier did
not only focus on the study of gene
expression signatures but also evaluated
changes in that microbiome as potential
predictors of complications in pediatric
Crohn's disease as shown in the left
panel
14 genera will associate with periodic
Crohn's disease four of which were
increased in particular aggregate vector
and Campylobacter
in contrast 10 older genera were
decreased in Crohn's disease more
importantly as shown in the right panel
two taxa Yamanaka Cassandra Thea
were also associated with development of
structuring disease and convinced Ella
and balloon ella are associated with
fistula in disease this resource are
currently being evaluated for inclusion
in the risk composite model I described
earlier
all right another very important is
tally derived from the crown chakra is
Foundation microbiome initiative is
related to the investigation of
microbiome based predictors of response
to an T integrate antibody another
biologic drug just for the treatment of
IBD for this 42 Crohn's disease patients
and 43 ulcerative colitis patients from
the Princeton cohort at MGH and
initiating and the integrins therapy
were including distally the primary
outcome was defined as clinical
remission at week 14 remission was
evaluated by reduction of on the HPI
and SSC a diseases course microbiome
were studies were done using stone
samples and analyze it shotgun metal
dynamics so what were the outcomes 31
patients achieved remission but by week
14 35 percent returned remission and the
clinical features associated with
remission we're shorter duration of
disease most likely Crohn's disease
diagnosis and less likely anti TNF alpha
exposure a biological agent juice
inability treatment regarding the
microbiome analysis before treatment
there is an increased abundance of only
two taxa associated with patients with
responded to treatment a miss an achieve
remission by week 14 in contrast when
microbial function was evaluated 13
pathways were upregulated in responders
at week 14 abundance of 5 taxa were
decreased including Pross birria enable
Anila warrants that is increased before
treatment as you see in the upper palate
they also found a decrease in 17
biological pathways including most of
those upregulated at baseline before
treatment now importantly the
implemented and network and network
analysis neural network analysis to
integrate the tray and to integrate and
trained the system to incorporate
clinical parameters microbiome microbial
taxa abundance and microbial pathways
this led to the to an increased
predicted value of response to treatment
with an IOC of 0.87 clinical parameters
alone had only an IOC of point 69 so
this important result should not only
support the use of MicroBot mercurial
signatures as prognostic markers but how
the use of artificial intelligence can
help to make sense of all this
information coming from the omics
analysis finally I will highlight
current efforts in the area of molecular
endoscopy for prediction or response to
treatment as most of you know anti TNF
alpha antibodies used in IBD therapy
work by binding both the soluble and
membrane membrane bound TNF alpha in
this study the hypothesis was that
quantification of the levels of membrane
bound TNF alpha in the patient's ood
markers patients mucosa can identify
responders to TNF alpha therapy to test
this hypothesis FS EF FITC label anti
TNF alpha antibody also known as a de
Lima was deliver topically via spray
catheter confocal laser endoscopy was
used to visualize cells with membrane
bound TNF alpha
the study was made in 25 constancies
patients with active disease the finest
Crohn's disease activity index bigger
than 150 molecular endoscopy was done
before treatment and this was date zero
at the Lima adalimumab treatment it
started seven days later and response
was measured by the reduction of Incan
disease activity Indies and day 31 and
91 no response was defined as need for
surgery as shown in the right panel as
Una's predicted patients with a high
levels of membrane-bound tnf-alpha
responded to hunt it in an anti TNF
alpha therapy patients with low levels
of anti TNF alpha in the membrane did
not respond to therapy
overall
96 percent of patients with high levels
of TNF alpha and a membrane respond to
treatment in contrast only 15% with of
patients with low levels of TNF alpha
responded to treatment the assay was
highly sensitive and specific and very
high positive and negative predictive
values and a more recent study published
by the same group also phone found that
patients with high levels of integral
alpha for beta 7 in the membrane were
better responders to ante integrate
theta P with padule-- smart compared to
those with low levels of membrane bound
integral alright so in summary I
highlighted very exciting progress made
in the identification of gene expression
microbiome and endoscopic prognostic
signatures that could be useful in
predicting complications like structural
and penetrating
aggressive discourse characterized by
chronic chronically active disease with
frequent relapse and need for treatment
installation and this molecular and
microbial signatures may also predict
response to treatment okay so given all
this experimental evidence
is clear that client clinical
phenotyping is just the tip of the
iceberg in prognosis and personalized
IBD treatment and therefore did you know
phenotype in of patients at the
molecular level is needed to advance the
concept of precision medicine in IBD it
also appears that multi omics data
integration seems to be key for
generation of prognostic classifiers
with improved predictive value for
patient certification in order to decide
efficacious personalized treatments
early in the disease okay so now despite
this advances several challenges exist
still lay ahead in particular related to
data collection and integration there is
a big need for harmonized data and some
sample collection for subsequent
multi-omics data generation and
integration challenges are also in the
integration of electronic health records
will multi-omics data and they need to
develop artificial intelligence tools to
support integration and analysis a very
important need is the invalidation of
candidate prognosis biomarkers in
longitudinal prospective cohorts and
inception cohorts which are ethnically
diverse and even more important
assessments of the clinical utility of
these markers in rigorous randomized
controlled trials to demonstrate
improvement in patient outcomes and cost
effective care as an approach to
circumvent these challenges the Crohn's
and Colitis foundation is building the
largest repository of IBD bio samples
and linked patients data in which
harmonized protocols and methods are
used to enroll patients and collect
samples these samples will be used for
harmonized generation of multi-omics
profiles that can be integrated with
electronic health records
IBD Plexus is therefore a research
platform that provides specialized
biobank infrastructure analytical
platforms for data mining
central reference labs where samples
will be converted into molecular data
using harmonized
protocols with the highest industry
standards and finally plexus also
confers an infrastructure with high
performance computing and research
Porter for access data
I believe plexus consists of four
research cohort two-wheeler cohorts that
collect patient-reported outcomes and
data on quality of care data they are
called IBD corals and IBD partners and
there are about two additional cohorts
an old prospective cohort called a spark
and risk the inception cohort I
described earlier both called clinical
data and bio samples in particular a
spark is a prospective adult cohort that
aims to enroll 7,000 patients by the end
of 2020 clinical data bio samples will
be collected risk is the legacy
pediatric inception cohort cons that
concept and founded by the Crown Chakra
foundations for the last 10 years this
cohort provided the groundbreaking work
on prediction of complications described
earlier and about 1,000 pediatric
patients were involved and by the
samples were also collected so in
conclusion I showed you today and I hope
I convince you that very exciting
advances have been made in the last
decade in regard to integrating
genotyping and deep clinical Molech and
molecular phenotyping for IBD prognosis
in particular the prognosis of a
structuring and penetrating complication
at diagnosis the prognosis of aggressive
disease occurs characterized by
persistent relapses and the need for
brock escalation and finally prediction
of response to biological therapy
altogether this prognostic
classifiers my help doctors decide at
diagnosis and with precision in which
patients to implement a state a step up
or a top-down approach for effective
treatment this studies also are opening
the doors to identify new targets for
drug discovery of therapies tailored to
the biological features of these
patients together this research
and future research including research
derive from the IBD plexus platform that
the Crohn's and Colitis foundation is
building is paving the path towards
precision medicine in IBD however more
work still required for the forest
clinical implementation and changed in
patient outcomes thank you very much and
I'm very glad to take questions Thank
You dr. haataja laurenza for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left to your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on the screen
and click the send button mines name
through many as many of your questions
as we have time for so let's get started
our first question is you present a data
related to the use of molecular markers
for prediction of disease course in
response to treatment has any work been
done regarding the prediction of side
effects of current bit IBD treatments
yeah thank you for that actually that's
a very good question and there are at
least three samples of genetic variants
that are associated with toxicity to two
theories a type of drug that is commonly
used to treat IBD first is
well-established that genetic
polymorphisms in the thiopurine
methyltransferase which is also known as
TPMT it's to reduce TPMT activity and
this results in the accumulation of a
toxic metabolite of Tyre file proteins
which is associated with development of
my-my-my low toxicity another
polymorphism that increases the toxicity
of thiopurines is the Neelix hydraulics
also known as nuit
15 gene this is nib is correct it is
associated with loci leukopenia in
patients exposed to thiopurines and a
third polymorphism is in is the class to
actually gene region that has been
so she ate without pancreatitis in
patients exposed to thiopurines and we
predict that there would be more work
and the identification of a
polymorphisms rig linked to the
side-effects of biological treatment as
well our next question is our
environmental factors being studied for
prediction of disease course yeah thank
you for that question this is a very
timely question as I mentioned in my
presentation is smoking which is one of
the most studied environmental factors
in IBD is related with bad prognosis of
Crohn's disease however it's important
to understand the role of all
environmental factors in disease
susceptibility and prognosis but our aim
in mind the Crohn's and Colitis
foundation recently launched an
initiative to identify biological
signatures of this subject ability and
progression and in response to
environmental exposures in particular
these are the studies are currently
evaluating the identification of
microbial signatures brain imaging
signatures and by school vascular
signatures to predict frequent disease
relapse in response to exposure to
psychological stress he the daily
perceive a stress or early life stress
we're also searching for antiviral
antibody signatures in response to
hit-and-run virus exposures that can
trigger disease relapse if positive a
simple blood test analyzed analyzing
landed eyes using viral multi peptide
arise might predict the development of
frequent residual lips course in
response to viral exposures so and
finally the periodic risk cohort that I
mentioned are also evaluating the
signature epigenetic signatures to
evaluate the role as predictors of
complications so in conclusion the
exposome field is growing in IBD and I'm
sure that it will make part of the
armamentarium of measurements that will
support effective precision medicine in
IBD I'd like to once again thank thank
dr. Hurtado Lorenzo for his presentation
I would also like to think lappers for
making today's educational webcasts
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through September of 2018 you will
receive an email from laberd's letting
you know when this webcast will be
available for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and we hope to see you again soon
goodbye